Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The S-Bahn commuter train rattled along in the darkness towards the eastern side of Berlin. Slowly, the cityscape gave way to the sprawling suburbia of Friedrichsfelder. It was here, in the early hours of August 13, 1939, that Lena Budzinski disembarked. Walking alone, she headed towards the nearby Allotment Garden.
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。柏林的S-Bahn通勤列车在黑暗中向柏林东部疾驰而去。城市景观慢慢让位于弗里德里希斯费尔德（Friedrichsfelder）广阔的郊区。1939年8月13日凌晨，莉娜·布津斯基（Lena Budzinski）就是在这里下了车。她独自一人步行，朝着附近的分配花园（Allotment Garden）走去。
Located throughout Berlin, Allotment Gardens allowed city dwellers to embrace a quasi-rural lifestyle. They could purchase or rent a modest plot of land on garden grounds to cultivate their own crops or raise small livestock. During the day, the gardens were peaceful. Narrow paths wove through the ornamental fruit trees and fields of homegrown vegetables. Gardeners tended to their little patch of countryside to the ambient sounds of the resident chickens, pigs and goats.
分配花园遍布柏林，让城市居民能够享受一种准乡村的生活方式。他们可以在花园地块购买或租用一小块土地，种植自己的农作物或饲养小牲畜。白天，花园里一片宁静。狭窄的小路穿过观赏性的果树和自家种植的蔬菜地。园丁们在鸡、猪和山羊的鸣叫声中照料着他们的一小片田园。
The Friedrichsfelder gardens also provided a direct route from the train station to the nearby Tenemann housing, servicing local residents like Lena Budzinski. As night fell, streetlights, lanterns and wood fire stoves bashed the gardens in a warm glow. Yet, the atmosphere within the grounds had changed in recent times. The Nazi Party had issued regulations that prevented the illumination of public spaces at night. It wasn't an official blackout, but more of a preparation for things to come.
弗里德里希斯费尔德的花园还提供了一条从火车站通往附近特内曼（Tenemann）住宅区的直接路线，为像莉娜·布津斯基这样的当地居民提供服务。夜幕降临，路灯、灯笼和木柴炉将花园笼罩在温暖的光辉中。然而，最近一段时间，花园内的气氛发生了变化。纳粹党发布了禁止在夜间照亮公共场所的规定。这并不是正式的灯火管制，而更像是为即将到来的事情做准备。
To help navigate the darkness and avoid collisions, citizens pinned phosphorescent badges that absorbed sunlight to the front of their clothing, making the badges glow green at night. As Lena Budzinski wandered alone through the Friedrichsfelder Allotment Garden, her movements were highlighted by the pale green glow of her badge. Lena was almost home when she heard footsteps approaching from behind. They started gaining pace. Lena panicked and started running towards her house, prompting the person behind her to speed up.
为了帮助在黑暗中辨别方向并避免碰撞，市民们将吸收阳光的磷光徽章别在衣服前，使徽章在夜间发出绿光。当莉娜·布津斯基独自在弗里德里希斯费尔德分配花园中漫步时，她徽章发出的淡绿色光芒突显了她的行踪。莉娜快到家时，听到身后传来脚步声。脚步声开始加快。莉娜惊慌失措，开始向家跑去，这促使身后的人也加快了速度。
As Lena pushed through her front gate, she was hit hard over the head, causing her to crumble to the ground. Momentarily concussed, Lena could only watch as a manly figure appeared over her. He was breathing quickly and heavily, trying to catch his breath. The man didn't utter a word before shoving a knife into Lena's back. He pulled it out and stabbed Lena three more times before fleeing. A knife-wielding assailant was active in Friedrichsfelder and local women needed to be warned. Yet, his actions didn't make the papers, and would soon be superseded altogether by
当莉娜推开前门时，她的头部遭到重击，导致她瘫倒在地。莉娜短暂地陷入昏迷，只能看着一个男人的身影出现在她上方。他呼吸急促而沉重，试图平复呼吸。那人一言不发，就将一把刀刺入莉娜的背部。他拔出刀，又刺了莉娜三下，然后逃之夭夭。一名持刀袭击者在弗里德里希斯费尔德活动，当地女性需要被警告。然而，他的行为并没有见报，而且很快就被完全取代了，
an even bigger story that broke weeks later, on Friday, September 1, 1939. Hitler visits the besieging army during his tour in conquered Poland, which is subjugated and partitioned. The defending army shattered by the lightning strokes of the Blitzkrieg, the Nazi fear has the air of a conqueror, as he surveys the artillery bombardment of Warsaw, which still resists, but cannot resist much longer, a capital city wrapped in flame and horror. Danzig, Hitler in the city, the dispute over which led to the European War. This Nazi demonstration was staged the day before Hitler flew back to Berlin and made
几周后，即1939年9月1日星期五，发生了一个更大的新闻。希特勒在征服波兰期间访问了围攻军队，波兰被征服并瓜分。防守军队被闪电战的雷霆一击击碎，纳粹的恐惧像征服者一样笼罩着天空，他视察了华沙的炮火轰炸，华沙仍在抵抗，但无法再坚持太久，这座首都城市被火焰和恐怖所笼罩。但泽（Danzig），希特勒在城中，关于这座城市的争端导致了欧洲战争。这次纳粹的示威活动是在希特勒飞回柏林并发表讲话的前一天进行的，
his latest speech suggesting peace, which Great Britain and France reject. Hitler faced with the prospect of a long, relentless war. Unbeknownst to Lena, she was not the first one to be attacked in the Friedrichsfelder Garden. In recent times, a lone perpetrator had been lurking around at night, using the pre-war blackout preparation to his advantage. Hiding in the shadows of the looming trees or makeshift sheds, he'd wait until he saw the familiar green glow of a phosphorescent badge.
他最新的演讲暗示和平，但被英国和法国拒绝。希特勒面临着一场漫长而无情的战争的前景。莉娜不知道的是，她并不是第一个在弗里德里希斯费尔德花园遇袭的人。最近，一名独行罪犯一直在夜间潜伏，利用战前的灯火管制准备作为掩护。他躲在参天大树或临时棚屋的阴影中，等待着，直到看到磷光徽章那熟悉的绿光。
If it was pinned to a lone woman, the man would leap out from his hiding place and shine a torch directly into the woman's eyes, rendering her momentarily blinded and disorientated. He'd then loudly bombard her with vulgar sexual remarks or threats. His behaviour escalated over time, and the verbal abuse soon turned physical. He would grab, grope and punch his victims, sometimes even choking them to prevent them from calling out for help. In one instance, a woman managed to let out a scream before the perpetrator gripped his hands around her throat.
如果徽章别在一名落单女性身上，那个人就会从藏身处跳出来，用手电筒直接照向女人的眼睛，使她瞬间失明并失去方向感。然后，他会大声地用粗俗的性言论或威胁来轰炸她。他的行为随着时间的推移而升级，言语辱骂很快变成了身体攻击。他会抓住、猥亵并殴打受害者，有时甚至掐住她们的脖子以阻止她们呼救。有一次，一名女子在被凶手掐住喉咙前成功发出了一声尖叫。
He was unaware that the woman's husband and one of his friends were waiting nearby and overheard the commotion. They rushed over and managed to tackle the assailant to the ground while yelling for the police. Fueled by fear, the man managed to overpower them and break free, fleeing into the surrounding bushes. Seemingly learning from this mistake, the man took to disabling his victims first by striking them over the head with a heavy object so that they couldn't call out for help.
他不知道女子的丈夫和他的一个朋友就在附近，听到了骚动。他们冲了过来，设法将袭击者扑倒在地，同时大声呼喊警察。在恐惧的驱使下，那人设法制服了他们并挣脱开来，逃进了周围的灌木丛中。似乎从这次错误中吸取了教训，那人开始先用重物击打受害者的头部，使她们无法呼救，从而先将她们制服。
He also began carrying a knife. So far, around 30 other women had been targeted, but none had been able to get a good look at the perpetrator. As he hadn't yet seriously harmed anyone, the case wasn't treated as a high priority, and with the news dominated by the ongoing actions of the German armed forces, most local residents remained unaware of the looming threat. It wasn't until Lena Budzinski was stabbed outside her home that police realised that they were dealing with a serious offender.
他还开始携带一把刀。到目前为止，大约有30名其他女性成为了目标，但没有人能看清袭击者的长相。由于他还没有严重伤害任何人，案件并未被视为高度优先事项，而且随着新闻被德国军队的持续行动所占据，大多数当地居民仍然没有意识到迫在眉睫的威胁。直到莉娜·布津斯基在家门外被刺伤，警方才意识到他们正在处理一名严重的罪犯。
He laid low for a while, which kept the police at bay. But unable to resist his urges, the assailant eventually continued his spree, reverting back to scaring women with his flashlight and verbal taunts to avoid an immediate reaction from police. It took four months before his desire to kill returned. News of the serial attacker spread slowly through word of mouth, but those who were aware of the lurking danger weren't able to do much about it. With the war underway, the output needed from Germany's factories was more demanding than
他潜伏了一段时间，这让警方无从下手。但无法抑制自己的冲动，袭击者最终继续了他的暴行，又回到了用手电筒恐吓女性并进行言语挑衅的老路，以避免引起警方的直接反应。四个月后，他杀人的欲望才再次出现。连环袭击者的消息通过口耳相传缓慢传播，但那些意识到潜伏危险的人对此无能为力。随着战争的进行，德国工厂的产出需求比
ever. Women were forced to continue working well into the late hours, producing industrial materials or the weaponry necessary to sustain the Nazi war machine. There was little they could do except hope they wouldn't cross paths with the attacker on their way home. On Thursday, December 14, 19-year-old factory worker Herta Jablinski finished her late shift and boarded the S-Bahn headed for her home in Friedrichsfelder. It was around 1.13am by the time she disembarked outside of the local allotment gardens and
以往任何时候都更加迫切。女性被迫在深夜继续工作，生产工业材料或维持纳粹战争机器所需的武器。除了祈祷自己在回家的路上不会遇到袭击者之外，她们别无他法。12月14日星期四，19岁的工厂女工赫塔·雅布林斯基（Herta Jablinski）结束了晚班，登上了前往弗里德里希斯费尔德家中的S-Bahn列车。当她在当地分配花园外下车时，时间大约是凌晨1点13分，
began on her path home. As she made her way through the dark, she heard footsteps closing in behind her. Herta paused and looked over her shoulder. While she couldn't see anything but darkness, she could feel someone else's presence. Panic washed over her. Herta broke out in a sprint, desperate to get to the safety of home. But the footsteps started up again, increasing in speed until she could feel the person right behind her.
开始走上回家的路。当她穿过黑暗时，她听到身后传来逼近的脚步声。赫塔停下脚步，回头看去。虽然她除了黑暗什么也看不见，但她能感觉到另一个人的存在。恐慌席卷了她。赫塔开始冲刺，拼命想回到安全的家中。但脚步声再次响起，速度越来越快，直到她能感觉到那个人就在她身后。
All of a sudden, Herta felt a heavy thud to her head. She fell over and was immediately overcome by a stabbing pain. A man stood over her, silently forcing a knife into her neck over and over. Using all her strength, Herta managed to let out a scream. It worked to spook the man, and he quickly fled the scene. The Friedrichsfelder attacker had struck again. Just like he had done after stabbing Lena Budzinski, he kept a low profile for several weeks until the police investigations dissipated.
突然，赫塔感到头部受到重重一击。她倒在地上，随即感到一阵刺痛。一个男人站在她上方，默默地将一把刀一次又一次地刺入她的脖子。赫塔用尽全身力气，成功发出了一声尖叫。这吓跑了那个男人，他迅速逃离了现场。弗里德里希斯费尔德的袭击者再次作案。就像他在刺伤莉娜·布津斯基后所做的那样，他保持低调了几周，直到警方的调查平息。
Once he felt like he was in the clear, he returned to his hunting ground and eased back into his spree with minor confrontations, getting a kick out of scaring the women who passed the by. Occasionally, he elevated into physical assaults, but nothing that would provoke police into an active manhunt. This time, it took eight months before his urge to kill returned. At around 1.30 a.m. on Saturday, July 27, 1940, 25-year-old Gertrude Nisvant walked quickly through the Friedrichsfelder Gardens.
一旦他觉得安全了，他就回到了他的狩猎场，通过轻微的对抗重新开始了暴行，以恐吓路过的女性为乐。偶尔，他会升级为身体攻击，但没有引起警方进行积极的搜捕。这一次，过了八个月，他杀人的欲望才再次出现。1940年7月27日星期六凌晨1点30分左右，25岁的格特鲁德·尼斯万特（Gertrude Nisvant）快速穿过弗里德里希斯费尔德花园。
It soon dawned on her that she was being followed. Gertrude didn't live in the area, but had taken the S-Bahn to visit her parents who lived nearby. Although she hadn't heard anything about the spade of attacks, her instincts immediately sensed danger. Gertrude picked up the pace. The person walking in the shadows behind did the same. Adrenaline soared through Gertrude's veins, and everything in her body told her to run.
她很快意识到自己被跟踪了。格特鲁德不住在这个地区，但她乘S-Bahn去探望住在附近的父母。虽然她没有听说过这一连串的袭击事件，但她的直觉立刻感觉到了危险。格特鲁德加快了步伐。走在阴影中的那个人也做了同样的事情。肾上腺素在格特鲁德的血管中激增，她身体里的每一个细胞都在告诉她快跑。
She reassured herself it was likely just another train passenger making their way home and managed to remain calm. When she finally reached her parents' home, relief washed over her. But as Gertrude made her way to the front porch, she heard footsteps behind her. She turned around and came face-to-face with a man she didn't recognize, his face barely visible through the darkness. Although Gertrude realized the man had been following her, she assumed he had relatively innocuous intentions.
她安慰自己，这可能只是另一个回家的火车乘客，并设法保持冷静。当她终于到达父母家时，如释重负。但当格特鲁德走向前廊时，她听到了身后的脚步声。她转过身，面对着一个她不认识的男人，在黑暗中几乎看不清他的脸。虽然格特鲁德意识到这个男人一直在跟踪她，但她认为他的意图相对无害。
Yet he seemed genuinely taken aback by how calm Gertrude was. She stood there silently staring at him. Eventually, the man felt compelled to break the awkward silence. Are you going in there? he asked, indicating towards the house. Gertrude replied curtly, of course. She didn't think the man was dangerous, but wanted him to leave her alone. She warned, leave or else I will yell.
然而，他似乎对格特鲁德的冷静感到非常惊讶。她静静地站在那里盯着他。最终，那个人感到有必要打破尴尬的沉默。“你要进去吗？”他问道，指着房子方向。格特鲁德简短地回答：“当然。”她不认为这个男人很危险，但想让他离她远点。她警告说：“离开，否则我会大叫。”
The man raised his arm, do not cry yet, he said. He then hit Gertrude hard, forcing her to the ground. As she lay there incapacitated, the man stood over her and stabbed her in the neck. He removed the knife and stabbed her again, this time near her groin. Despite the deep wound in Gertrude's neck, she managed to let out a scream. It took the man completely by surprise. Shocked, he fled into the darkness. Gertrude Nisvant was the first victim who sustained an injury that appeared to be sexually
那人举起手臂，“先别叫，”他说。然后他重重地打了格特鲁德一下，将她打倒在地。当她瘫倒在那里失去行动能力时，那人站在她上方，刺伤了她的脖子。他拔出刀，又刺了她一下，这次是在腹股沟附近。尽管格特鲁德的脖子受了重伤，但她还是成功发出了一声尖叫。这让那个人大吃一惊。震惊之下，他逃进了黑暗中。格特鲁德·尼斯万特是第一个受到看起来具有性动机伤害的受害者，
motivated, adding a new layer of complexity to the crimes. This time, the perpetrator didn't wait months for the trail to go well and truly cold before striking again. Three weeks later, on the evening of Wednesday, August 21, 40-year-old Yuli Shumaha was walking home alone through the Friedrichsfelder Gardens. All of a sudden, a flash of light sparked in front of her. Yuli had become so accustomed to the darkness that the bright light caused her physical pain.
这为这些罪行增添了新的复杂性。这一次，凶手没有等几个月让线索彻底冷却后再作案。三周后，8月21日星期三晚上，40岁的尤利·舒马哈（Yuli Shumaha）独自穿过弗里德里希斯费尔德花园回家。突然，一道闪光在她面前闪过。尤利已经习惯了黑暗，强光让她感到身体疼痛。
Realizing the light had come from a flashlight-wielding man, Yuli angrily yelled at him to stop. He didn't respond. Instead, he struck Yuli over the head with a heavy blunt object, rendering her unconscious. When Yuli came too, she realized she'd been raped. There was no sign of her attacker, and police believed he might have fled the scene after falsely believing Yuli was dead. She wasn't the only one who survived one of his more serious assaults. Lena Budzinski, Fjerta Jablinski and Gertrude Nisvant had all also miraculously survived
意识到光线来自一个拿着手电筒的男人，尤利愤怒地大喊让他停下。他没有回应。相反，他用一个沉重的钝器击打尤利的头部，使她昏迷不醒。当尤利醒来时，她意识到自己被强奸了。袭击者不见踪影，警方认为他可能在错误地认为尤利已死后逃离了现场。她并不是唯一一个在他更严重的袭击中幸存下来的人。莉娜·布津斯基、赫塔·雅布林斯基和格特鲁德·尼斯万特也都奇迹般地幸存了下来，
their ordeals. At the offender's best efforts, he hadn't managed to kill anyone. Having now carried out a rape, there was no doubt the attacks were sexually motivated. Police began to suspect the assailant might have intended to rape the other women too, but had been forced to flee mid-attack after some managed to scream out. Once again, the severity of the attacks diminished in the wake of Yuli's rape, but they didn't stop completely. At least a dozen more women reported being harassed by a flashlight-wielding man in the
经历了这些磨难。尽管凶手尽了最大努力，但他没能杀死任何人。现在已经实施了强奸，毫无疑问，这些袭击具有性动机。警方开始怀疑袭击者可能也打算强奸其他女性，但在一些人成功尖叫后被迫中途逃跑。再一次，袭击的严重程度在尤利被强奸后有所减弱，但并没有完全停止。至少还有十几名女性报告在弗里德里希斯费尔德花园遭到一名手持手电筒的男子的骚扰，警方认为可能还有更多人选择不站出来。
Friedrichsfelder Gardens, with police believing there might have been more who chose not to come forward. On Sunday, August 25, 1940, an explosion rocked Berlin. Aircraft under the command of UK Prime Minister Winston Churchill dropped a bomb on the city in retaliation for a similar attack carried out by German planes over London. It was the first time bombs had ever fallen on Berlin, and while the only thing destroyed was a garden house, the impact on morale was immense. Up until this point, the people of Berlin believed their military leadership when they
1940年8月25日星期日，一场爆炸震撼了柏林。在英国首相温斯顿·丘吉尔的指挥下，飞机向该市投下了一枚炸弹，以报复德国飞机在伦敦进行的类似袭击。这是炸弹第一次落在柏林，虽然唯一被摧毁的是一座花园小屋，但对士气的影响是巨大的。直到这一点，柏林人民还相信他们的军事领导层，当他们
said the British would never bomb Germany. Now, anything was possible. Fearing another more deadly attack, German citizens continued to live each night in perpetual darkness, hoping to prevent British aircraft from hitting their targets. Berlin's official war-induced blackout mimicked the one currently in place in London to discourage German attacks. Windows were painted black, streetlights were dimmed, and the few vehicles on the road had their headlights blocked.
说英国永远不会轰炸德国时。现在，一切皆有可能。由于担心另一次更致命的袭击，德国公民每晚继续生活在永恒的黑暗中，希望阻止英国飞机击中目标。柏林官方的战争灯火管制模仿了伦敦目前实行的管制，以阻止德国的袭击。窗户被漆成黑色，路灯变暗，路上仅有的几辆车也遮住了前灯。
Within days of initiating the official blackout, the Nazi party severely increased punishments for those who took advantage of the darkened conditions to commit crime. A few months in prison for a crime committed during the day became a death sentence if it were committed at night. This didn't deter the Friedrichsfelder garden attacker. With more areas now consumed by darkness, his hunting ground only increased. By Friday, September 20, 1940, one month had passed since the attempted murder of Uli Schumacher.
在启动官方灯火管制后的几天内，纳粹党严厉加重了对那些利用黑暗条件犯罪的人的惩罚。白天犯罪判处几个月监禁，如果在夜间犯罪则会被判处死刑。这并没有阻止弗里德里希斯费尔德花园的袭击者。随着现在有更多的地区被黑暗吞噬，他的狩猎场只会增加。到1940年9月20日星期五，距离尤利·舒马哈被谋杀未遂已经过去了一个月。
Gerter Kargel was riding the S-Bahn home after a long day. Due to the blackout measures, the S-Bahn was operating with only one quarter of its usual lighting, and all the windows were covered. The dim lights coupled with the motion of the train slowly lulled Gerter off to sleep. When she jolted awake, she realized she'd accidentally slept through her intended stop. Gerter quickly disembarked at the next station, where she waited in the dark for the next train to take her back in the opposite direction. With the train exterior's void of light, certain spots had been covered with phosphorus
格特·卡格尔（Gerter Kargel）在漫长的一天后乘S-Bahn回家。由于灯火管制措施，S-Bahn的照明仅为平时的四分之一，所有窗户都被遮住了。昏暗的灯光加上列车的晃动，慢慢地让格特昏昏欲睡。当她惊醒时，她意识到自己不小心睡过了站。格特迅速在下一站下车，在黑暗中等待下一班列车，以便朝相反方向返回。由于列车外部没有灯光，某些地方被涂上了磷光
paint so they'd emit a small glow at night. Eventually, Gerter saw the glow of the inbound train, followed by the clickety-clack sound of its wheels as it slowed to a stop. She boarded and took a seat, with the train continuing onwards until Gerter was the only one left in the compartment. With men away at war, the trains were often only populated by women. By nightfall, many women were at home looking after their families, leaving the local trains near empty, with only late shift workers and transportation staff on board.
油漆，以便在夜间发出微弱的光。最终，格特看到了进站列车发出的光，随后是车轮减速停止时的咔哒声。她上了车并找了个座位，列车继续前行，直到车厢里只剩下格特一个人。由于男人都在打仗，火车上通常只有女性。夜幕降临后，许多女性都在家照顾家人，导致当地火车几乎空无一人，只有晚班工人和运输人员在车上。
It was around 11.30pm by the time the train departed Vulhider Station. As it barreled onwards towards Friedrichshagen, a man approached Gerter. Once he was within arm's reach, he suddenly launched himself at her, wrapping his hands at her throat. Gerter struggled against him, attempting to drag him away towards the sliding door on the side of the train. The door could be manually pulled open even when the train was in motion, so Gerter recognized this as an opportunity to save herself.
当火车离开Vulhider站时，时间大约是晚上11点30分。当它向弗里德里希斯哈根（Friedrichshagen）疾驰而去时，一个男人走向格特。一旦他进入触手可及的范围，他突然扑向她，双手掐住她的喉咙。格特与他搏斗，试图将他拖向火车侧面的滑动门。即使在火车行驶时，门也可以手动拉开，所以格特意识到这是一个自救的机会。
She managed to make it to the door, with the man's hands still wrapped around her throat, but she lost consciousness before she was able to slide it open. By this point, the train was only minutes from the next station. Fearing a boarding passenger would realize what he'd done, Gerter's attacker opened the sliding door. With the train still speeding along at roughly 40-50mph, he pushed Gerter out. Her body was swept up by the fierce wind, flying through the air for several moments before hitting the ground with a hard thud.
她设法到达了门口，男人的手仍然掐着她的喉咙，但在她能够拉开门之前，她失去了知觉。此时，火车距离下一站只有几分钟的路程。担心上车的乘客会意识到他做了什么，格特的袭击者打开了滑动门。在火车仍以大约40-50英里/小时的速度行驶时，他把格特推了出去。她的身体被猛烈的风卷起，在空中飞了几秒钟，然后重重地撞在地上。
The following morning, a passer-by was walking near the train tracks beyond Vulhider Station when they heard screams for help. They went to investigate and found Gerter cargo lying in pain. Her attacker had mistaken her for dead when he pushed her unconscious body off the train, and as luck would have it, Gerter had landed on a soft pile of sand. Had she landed on the rocky surrounds, she would have most certainly died from impact. Instead, Gerter had only suffered a concussion and multiple abrasions. Gerter's personal belongings were discovered a little further up the track, indicating
第二天早上，一名路人走在Vulhider站外的铁轨附近时，听到了求救的尖叫声。他们去调查，发现格特·卡格尔痛苦地躺在那里。她的袭击者在把她昏迷的身体推下火车时误以为她已经死了，幸运的是，格特落在一堆松软的沙子上。如果她落在岩石周围，她肯定会因撞击而死亡。相反，格特只遭受了脑震荡和多处擦伤。格特的个人物品在轨道前方一点被发现，表明
her attacker had thrown them out the door immediately after pushing Gerter out. Yet, when Gerter reported her ordeal to the police, they were skeptical. Given there was no sign that Gerter had been sexually assaulted or robbed, police weren't convinced that a crime had taken place at all. They felt Gerter's story that a random stranger would strangle and push her out of a train for no reason was too far-fetched. When Gerter admitted she had had a few drinks before boarding the train and had fallen asleep during the trip, police believed the more likely scenario was that Gerter had been drunk and
她的袭击者在把格特推出去后立即把它们扔出了门。然而，当格特向警方报告她的遭遇时，他们持怀疑态度。鉴于没有迹象表明格特遭到性侵犯或抢劫，警方根本不相信发生了犯罪。他们认为格特关于一个陌生人无缘无故地掐住她并把她推下火车的说法太牵强了。当格特承认她在上火车前喝了几杯酒，并在旅途中睡着了时，警方认为更有可能的情况是格特喝醉了，
accidentally fell off the moving train in the dark. She then made up the story about the assault to cover her own missteps. Train-related accidents and fatalities weren't uncommon during the blackout, with numerous passengers falling off of trains or platforms due to the lack of lighting. It was a price the Nazi party was willing to pay, as they were at the height of their power and enemy bombings continued in Berlin, prolonging the need for the blackouts. Two weeks later, 20-year-old Gertrude Ditter stood alone at the Rumsburg train station waiting for the S-Bahn.
在黑暗中不小心从行驶的火车上掉了下来。然后她编造了袭击的故事来掩盖自己的失误。在灯火管制期间，与火车相关的事故和死亡并不罕见，由于缺乏照明，许多乘客从火车或站台上掉下来。这是纳粹党愿意付出的代价，因为他们正处于权力的巅峰，敌人的轰炸在柏林持续不断，延长了灯火管制的必要性。两周后，20岁的格特鲁德·迪特（Gertrude Ditter）独自站在Rumsburg火车站等待S-Bahn。
A man soon approached and struck up a conversation. Gertrude was charmed by him and gave him her home address when asked. It faced the allotment gardens in the neighbouring suburb of Friedrichsfelder. At around midday the following day, a member of the Nazi party went to Gertrude's home to speak to her about some personal matters. He knocked on the front door, but there was no response. He tried the door handle and was surprised to find it unlocked. He pushed the door open slightly and looked inside.
一个男人很快走过来并开始搭话。格特鲁德被他迷住了，在被问及时给了他家庭住址。它面向邻近的弗里德里希斯费尔德郊区的分配花园。第二天中午左右，一名纳粹党成员来到格特鲁德家，与她谈论一些私事。他敲了敲前门，但没有人回应。他试了试门把手，惊讶地发现门没锁。他轻轻推开门，向里面看去。
Blackout drapes were drawn across the windows, making it difficult to see much through the darkness. The man lit a match and as the flicker of light cast across the small dark kitchen, he spotted Gertrude's body propped up against a table with one of her hands resting on a bench. Gertrude's eyes were bloodshot and her long black hair was tucked behind her badly bruised neck, which also bore a deep wound. A fractured hyoid bone revealed that she had been strangled with intense force before being stabbed and dying of blood loss.
窗户上拉着灯火管制窗帘，很难透过黑暗看清东西。那人点燃了一根火柴，当微弱的光线投射在狭小黑暗的厨房里时，他发现格特鲁德的尸体靠在桌子上，一只手放在长凳上。格特鲁德的眼睛充血，她那头长长的黑发被别在她那淤青严重的脖子后面，脖子上还有一道深深的伤口。骨折的舌骨显示她在被刺伤并因失血过多死亡之前，曾被强力掐住。
Gertrude had no defensive wounds and her house wasn't in disarray, which indicated she likely knew her killer, and had willingly let him inside before he launched a swift and unexpected attack. Lying on the ground underneath Gertrude's right hand was a kitchen knife. It didn't contain any blood or foreign fingerprints, making it unlikely that it had been used against her. Instead, it had probably been knocked about during the scuffle, or Gertrude might have wielded it in defense.
格特鲁德没有防御性伤口，她的房子也没有凌乱，这表明她可能认识凶手，并且在凶手发动迅速而突然的袭击之前自愿让他进屋。躺在格特鲁德右手下方的地板上是一把厨房刀。它上面没有任何血迹或外来指纹，因此不太可能被用来对付她。相反，它可能是在扭打过程中被碰掉的，或者格特鲁德可能曾用它进行防御。
The murder weapon was deemed to be a pocket knife, which was nowhere to be found. Gertrude hadn't been sexually assaulted and nothing was taken from her house. Gertrude's two infant children were found asleep and unharmed in the living room, oblivious to what had taken place. Given that most of Gertrude's neighbors had been asleep at the time of the attack, no one had seen or heard anything suspicious. The blackout ensured the man had moved through the area completely unnoticed. Gertrude's injuries matched the Fridrichsfeldergarten attacker's MO to a T, leaving no doubt for the
谋杀武器被认定为一把折叠刀，但不知去向。格特鲁德没有遭到性侵犯，她的房子里也没有丢失任何东西。格特鲁德的两个幼儿被发现睡在客厅里，安然无恙，对发生的事情一无所知。鉴于格特鲁德的大多数邻居在袭击发生时都在睡觉，没有人看到或听到任何可疑的事情。灯火管制确保了那个人在完全不被注意的情况下在这一地区活动。格特鲁德的伤势与弗里德里希斯费尔德花园袭击者的作案手法完全吻合，这让
police that the same man was responsible. Given that this was his first successful murder, the efforts to identify him dramatically increased. Women who had survived the previous attacks were re-interviewed, and by piecing together their small recollections, police ascertained that the perpetrator was between 30 and 40 years old, around 170 cm tall, and with our quote, body facial expression. Some recalled he had been wearing a short leather jacket, sports shirt with an open collar, dark pants, and a blue visor cap. Some had seen him riding or pushing a bicycle.
警方毫无疑问是同一个人所为。鉴于这是他第一次成功的谋杀，查明他身份的努力大大加强。之前袭击的幸存者被重新询问，通过拼凑她们零星的回忆，警方确定凶手年龄在30到40岁之间，身高约170厘米，有着“身体面部表情”。一些人回忆说他穿着短皮夹克、开领运动衫、深色裤子和蓝色遮阳帽。有些人看到他骑着或推着自行车。
Posters containing these details were displayed throughout the Fridrichsfelder allotment gardens and surrounds, along with the offer of a 1000 rucks-marks reward. The posters read, For a long time in Colony Gutland and the surrounding area, solitary women have been immorally harassed and some have also been wounded with a knife, especially in the dark, by an unknown offender. It is to be assumed that the murder of Gertrude Ditter concerns the same offender. It is the duty of every citizen to actively participate in identifying this demon.
包含这些细节的海报被张贴在弗里德里希斯费尔德分配花园及其周边地区，并悬赏1000帝国马克。海报上写着：“长期以来，在Gutland殖民地及周边地区，独行女性一直受到不道德的骚扰，有些人还在黑暗中被不明身份的罪犯用刀刺伤。可以推测，格特鲁德·迪特的谋杀案涉及同一名罪犯。每一位公民都有义务积极参与识别这个恶魔。”
By this point the Fridrichsfelder garden attacks had been going on for over a year, but most local women still weren't fully aware of the lingering danger. Even though the wanted posters mentioned Gertrude Ditter's murder, they significantly downplayed the threat and failed to detail the offender's history of sexually motivated violence and rape. One newspaper encouraged for known sex offenders to be looked into, but the newspaper was published for the Reich Criminal Investigation Department and was only read by law enforcement personnel. Given that police had disregarded Gertrude Cargel's account of being strangled and thrown
到这一点，弗里德里希斯费尔德花园的袭击已经持续了一年多，但大多数当地女性仍然没有完全意识到潜伏的危险。尽管通缉海报提到了格特鲁德·迪特的谋杀案，但它们极大地淡化了威胁，未能详细说明罪犯有性动机暴力和强奸的历史。一家报纸鼓励调查已知的性犯罪者，但该报纸是为帝国刑事调查局出版的，仅供执法人员阅读。鉴于警方无视了格特·卡格尔关于被掐住并从S-Bahn上扔下的陈述，
from the S-Bahn as fictitious, a connection hadn't been made to the train line. Similarly, no one knew that Gertrude Ditter had met her killer at the Rumorsporg train station hours before she was attacked. Therefore, the stops along the train line weren't highlighted as significant areas in the police investigation and women continued riding the S-Bahn alone at night with no additional sense of vigilance. On the evening of November 4, 1940, 30-year-old Elizabeth Bendorf finished her late shift selling train tickets.
认为其是虚构的，因此没有将其与铁路线联系起来。同样，没有人知道格特鲁德·迪特在遇袭前几个小时在Rumorsporg火车站遇到了她的杀手。因此，铁路线沿线的站点没有被强调为警方调查的重要区域，女性继续在夜间独自乘坐S-Bahn，没有任何额外的警惕感。1940年11月4日晚上，30岁的伊丽莎白·本多夫（Elizabeth Bendorf）结束了她售卖火车票的晚班。
It had been less than a month since Gertrude Ditter had been murdered just a short walk from where Elizabeth now stood at the S-Bahn station in Friedrichsfelder. She boarded the train just after 11pm and sat down across from a mail passenger. They were the only two in the compartment, and as the train moved away from the station, the man struck up some small talk. By the time the train reached Hirschgarten station, he stood at the door of the compartment and looked out to the platform. No one else boarded their compartment, and the train took off once more.
距离格特鲁德·迪特在距离伊丽莎白现在所站的弗里德里希斯费尔德S-Bahn车站仅几步之遥的地方被谋杀，已经过去不到一个月了。她在晚上11点后上了火车，坐在一名男性乘客对面。他们是车厢里仅有的两个人，当火车驶离车站时，那个人开始闲聊。当火车到达Hirschgarten站时，他站在车厢门口，看向站台。没有其他人上他们的车厢，火车再次出发。
As soon as the train started moving, the man walked over to Elizabeth. He removed a thick piece of lead piping he had hidden up his jacket sleeve and brought it down hard on Elizabeth's head. She was temporarily concussed but regained consciousness relatively quickly and began screaming for help. Her cries were muted by the loud sounds of the train as it sped along the tracks, ensuring no other passengers could hear her. The man hit Elizabeth with the pipe over and over, until she eventually slumped down onto
火车一开动，那个人就走向伊丽莎白。他拿出一根藏在夹克袖子里的粗铅管，重重地砸在伊丽莎白的头上。她短暂地陷入昏迷，但很快恢复了知觉，开始尖叫求救。她的呼喊声被火车在轨道上疾驰的巨大声音所掩盖，确保没有其他乘客能听到她。那个人用管子一次又一次地击打伊丽莎白，直到她最终瘫倒在
the floor. The attacker then opened the compartment door with the intention of pushing Elizabeth's body into the rush of cold air outside. He turned around to grab her, but to his surprise, Elizabeth was still alive and had started inching away from him. Once again, he beat her repeatedly with the lead pipe. Elizabeth clung to consciousness but was no longer able to scream or fight back as her attacker dragged her towards the open door.
地板上。袭击者随后打开了车厢门，打算把伊丽莎白的身体推入外面疾驰的冷风中。他转过身去抓她，但令他惊讶的是，伊丽莎白还活着，并开始向远离他的方向挪动。他再次用铅管反复殴打她。伊丽莎白强撑着意识，但由于袭击者将她拖向敞开的门，她已经无法尖叫或反抗。
He continued pelting Elizabeth's back and kicking her body until the train descended towards the next station. He then started molesting her. Just before the train lost momentum, he pushed Elizabeth through the open door and out into the darkness. Like a ghetto cargo before her, Elizabeth Bendoff miraculously survived being thrown from the S-Bahn. She suffered a severe concussion and extensive injuries, and it took eight days of treatment
他继续投掷伊丽莎白的背部并踢她的身体，直到火车驶向下一站。然后他开始猥亵她。就在火车失去动力之前，他把伊丽莎白推过敞开的门，推入了黑暗中。像她之前的格特·卡格尔一样，伊丽莎白·本多夫奇迹般地在被从S-Bahn上扔下后幸存了下来。她遭受了严重的脑震荡和广泛的伤害，经过八天的治疗
in the hospital before she had recovered enough to be questioned by police. While Elizabeth could describe her attack, she couldn't identify the man responsible. Regardless, police no longer doubted a ghetto cargo's story. Neither Gerta nor Elizabeth got a clear look of the offender's face and the small descriptions they could provide conflicted one another. Still, police now had a new crime scene to examine for clues. They searched the S-Bahn, and while it was difficult to single out the attacker's fingerprints in the compartments due to it being such a high traffic area, they did find something
在医院里，她才恢复到足以接受警方询问的程度。虽然伊丽莎白可以描述她的袭击，但她无法识别负责的男人。无论如何，警方不再怀疑格特·卡格尔的故事。格特和伊丽莎白都没有看清凶手的脸，她们能提供的少量描述相互矛盾。尽管如此，警方现在有了新的犯罪现场来寻找线索。他们搜查了S-Bahn，虽然由于这是一个高流量区域，很难在车厢中挑出袭击者的指纹，但他们确实发现了一些
of significance. Behind one of the seat cushions, police uncovered the lead pipe that had been used to beat Elizabeth Bendoff. The blood-stained pipe was two inches thick and 20 inches long, with telephone cable inside and numbers printed on the exterior. It was unclear why the perpetrator had left it behind, but he did have the foresight to wipe down the section he'd been holding onto to remove his fingerprints. While any old piece of lead pipe would be near impossible to trace, the numbers on this
重要的事情。在其中一个座垫后面，警方发现了用来殴打伊丽莎白·本多夫的铅管。这根沾满血迹的管子有两英寸厚，20英寸长，里面有电话线，外部印有数字。目前尚不清楚为什么凶手把它留在了后面，但他确实有先见之明，擦掉了他握住的部分以去除指纹。虽然任何旧的铅管都几乎不可能追踪，但这些数字
pipe allowed police to identify it as having come from cable that was laid alongside the S-Bahn tracks around Ruhmersburg a year and a half prior. Police looked into the workers who had originally laid the cable and ruled them out as suspects one by one. There were only two other ways in which the piping could have been obtained. One of the workers could have haphazardly tossed it aside, with the attacker later stumbling upon it. The problem with this theory was that with Germany at war, scrap metal was valuable and
管子使警方能够确定它来自一年半前铺设在Ruhmersburg附近S-Bahn轨道旁边的电缆。警方调查了最初铺设电缆的工人，并将他们一一排除在嫌疑人之外。获得管道的方法只有另外两种。其中一名工人可能随手扔掉了它，袭击者后来偶然发现了它。这个理论的问题在于，随着德国处于战争状态，废金属很值钱，
therefore unlikely to be willfully discarded. Alternatively, the piping could have been stolen from the warehouse where the scrap pieces of cable were taken after the job was done. Thousands of people had access to the warehouse, meaning anyone could have swiped it. It is determined that the same piece of pipe had been used against Yuli Shumaha, thus confirming the Friedrichsfeldergarten and S-Bahn attacks were carried out by the same offender. But they were quick to realise the weapon wasn't the smoking gun they had anticipated. Given that no one had been killed on the S-Bahn, news of the attacks didn't spread and no
因此不太可能被故意丢弃。或者，管道可能是从仓库偷来的，工作完成后废弃的电缆碎片被带到了那里。成千上万的人可以进入仓库，这意味着任何人都可以偷走它。经确定，同一根管子曾被用于对付尤利·舒马哈，从而证实了弗里德里希斯费尔德花园和S-Bahn的袭击是由同一名罪犯实施的。但他们很快意识到，武器并不是他们预期的确凿证据。鉴于S-Bahn上没有人被杀，袭击的消息没有传播，也没有
increased safety measures were put in place. For the most part, life on the S-Bahn continued as normal. Just like he had with his attacks in the Friedrichsfeldergarten, the offender waited until police attention had waned and was focused elsewhere, before striking again. On the night of Tuesday, December 3, 1940, one month after the attack on Elizabeth Bendoff, the perpetrator rode the S-Bahn with a 15-inch iron rod concealed up his jacket sleeve. Given that Elizabeth had survived, he decided he would no longer engage his victims in small talk first.
采取了增加的安全措施。在很大程度上，S-Bahn上的生活照常进行。就像他在弗里德里希斯费尔德花园的袭击一样，凶手等到警方的注意力减弱并集中在其他地方后，才再次作案。1940年12月3日星期二晚上，在袭击伊丽莎白·本多夫一个月后，凶手带着一根藏在夹克袖子里的15英寸铁棒乘坐S-Bahn。鉴于伊丽莎白幸存了下来，他决定不再先与受害者闲聊。
The chance of them getting a good look at him was too risky. When he spotted 26-year-old nurse Elfrida Franca travelling alone in a compartment, he walked right up to her, pulled out his iron rod and struck her in the head without saying a word. Learning from his previous mistakes, this time he hit harder to ensure Elfrida would be completely incapacitated and unable to scream or try to escape. Elfrida was struck with such force that her skull was shattered and her brain damaged, killing her instantly.
她们看清他长相的机会风险太大了。当他发现26岁的护士埃尔弗里达·弗兰卡（Elfrida Franca）独自在车厢里旅行时，他径直走到她面前，掏出铁棒，一言不发地击中了她的头部。吸取了之前的教训，这次他打得更重，以确保埃尔弗里达完全失去行动能力，无法尖叫或试图逃跑。埃尔弗里达被击中，力度之大导致她的头骨破碎，大脑受损，当场死亡。
Her killer then pushed her body out of the train before it reached the next station. Less than half an hour later, 19-year-old Imgarde Fraser was walking alone along a quiet street, halfway between the Karlshorst and Ruhmersburg train stations. On the nearby tracks, the S-Bahn came to a stop. In minutes it was off again, the sound of its motor fading into the distance. Imgarde didn't have a moment to acknowledge what came next. Suddenly, a dark figure silently launched from the shadows, raising an iron rod in the air before bringing it down on Imgarde's head, knocking her out instantly.
她的杀手随后在火车到达下一站之前把她的尸体推了下去。不到半小时后，19岁的伊姆加德·弗雷泽（Imgarde Fraser）独自走在Karlshorst和Ruhmersburg火车站之间的一条安静街道上。在附近的轨道上，S-Bahn停了下来。几分钟后它又开走了，发动机的声音消失在远方。伊姆加德没有时间意识到接下来会发生什么。突然，一个黑影从阴影中悄无声息地冲了出来，举起一根铁棒，在伊姆加德的头上砸下，瞬间将她击昏。
She was hit three more times in quick succession, the rod crushing her skull. Imgarde's body was left out in the open street, where it was found at 4.30am. The dishevelled state of her clothing confirmed she'd been raped. Shockingly, despite her extensive head injuries, Imgarde was still alive. She was rushed to hospital with the detective by her side in case she regained consciousness and revealed any key information about the attack. Unfortunately, that never happened. Imgarde Fraser died later that day from a brain hemorrhage due to her severely fractured
她又被连续击中了三次，铁棒压碎了她的头骨。伊姆加德的尸体被留在空旷的街道上，于凌晨4点30分被发现。她衣衫不整的状态证实她被强奸了。令人震惊的是，尽管头部受了重伤，伊姆加德仍然活着。她被紧急送往医院，侦探守在她身边，以防她恢复知觉并透露有关袭击的任何关键信息。不幸的是，这从未发生。伊姆加德·弗雷泽因头骨严重骨折导致的脑出血于当天晚些时候死亡。
skull. In January 1933, the super salesman with the limp, Joseph Goebbels, helps catapulted off Hitler and the Nazis into power in Germany. His reward, the Ministry of Propaganda, is objective, the minds and souls of 80 million Germans. A hypnotic speaker, every word, every rehearsed gesture is coldly calculated to hit its mark. Imgarde is an art best achieved by genius, Goebbels has written. H.R.
1933年1月，跛脚的超级推销员约瑟夫·戈培尔（Joseph Goebbels）帮助希特勒和纳粹在德国掌权。他的奖励是宣传部，目标是8000万德国人的思想和灵魂。作为一名催眠式的演讲者，每一个字，每一个排练过的手势都经过冷酷的计算，以达到目的。“伊姆加德（Imgarde）是一门最好由天才实现的艺术，”戈培尔写道。H.R.
Trevor Roper tells how he does it. He had absolute control over the organs of propaganda, the press, the radio, everything. So they were centralized and what he wanted to say could be put before the German people without contradiction. What he did was to create the image of the party, the image of the Fuhrer. When Goebbels speaks to the German people who are strictly forbidden to listen to foreign broadcasts, radio wardens see that they listen. Joseph Goebbels was well aware that a serial killer was active in eastern Berlin.
特雷弗·罗珀（Trevor Roper）讲述了他如何做到这一点。“他绝对控制了宣传机构、报纸、广播，一切。所以它们是集中的，他想说的话可以在没有反驳的情况下呈现在德国人民面前。他所做的是创造党的形象，元首的形象。”当戈培尔向严禁收听外国广播的德国人民发表讲话时，广播管理员会确保他们收听。约瑟夫·戈培尔很清楚，一名连环杀手正在柏林东部活动。
He knew that the Yes Barn murderer, as he'd come to be known, had an extensive history of offending with his actions escalating over time. Now that the perpetrator was striking multiple times in one night, local women were in greater danger and Goebbels understood that there was little the police could do. Their resources were already stretched due to the war and the blackout-induced crime wave. They were also vastly inexperienced to tackle a case of this magnitude. Regardless, as the Minister of Propaganda, Goebbels didn't want any word of it getting
他知道，后来被称为“Yes Barn杀手”的凶手有着长期的犯罪史，且其行为随着时间的推移不断升级。现在，由于罪犯一晚多次作案，当地女性面临着更大的危险，而戈培尔明白警察能做的微乎其微。由于战争和灯火管制引发的犯罪浪潮，警方的资源已经捉襟见肘。他们也极其缺乏处理此类重大案件的经验。无论如何，作为宣传部长，戈培尔不希望任何关于此案的消息传
out. As detailed in the book as serial killer in Nazi Berlin, Goebbels wanted German citizens to fear the Nazi regime and not think they could get away with committing violent crimes. He also didn't want the German men who were fighting in the war to think they'd be better off protecting their loved ones at home. Consequently, the Yes Barn murderer was kept out of the press. A few posters requesting information about Alfreda Franka's murder were dotted around train stations, but they implied it was a one-off crime, not the work of a serial killer.
出去。正如《纳粹柏林连环杀手》一书中所详述的那样，戈培尔希望德国公民对纳粹政权感到恐惧，而不是认为他们可以逍遥法外地犯下暴力罪行。他也不希望在前线作战的德国男人认为，留在家里保护亲人会更好。因此，Yes Barn杀手的事迹被媒体封锁了。火车站周围张贴了一些征集阿尔弗雷达·弗兰卡谋杀案线索的海报，但它们暗示这只是一起孤立的犯罪，而非连环杀手所为。
Not only did this censorship put more women at risk, it also prevented anyone with information that could be helpful to the investigation from coming forward. Police did what they could within the limitations set by the government, offering a reward of 10,000 Reichsmarks for information pertaining to Alfreda's murder. This was a significant amount of money at the time, with a small home in the area costing around 150 Reichsmarks. Complicating matters was the unpredictability of the killer's behaviour. While he had a clear MO, his crimes weren't always carried out in the same manner or location.
这种审查制度不仅使更多的女性处于危险之中，还阻止了任何可能对调查有帮助的知情者挺身而出。警方在政府设定的限制内尽了最大努力，悬赏1万帝国马克征集有关阿尔弗雷达谋杀案的线索。这在当时是一笔巨款，因为该地区的一栋小房子大约只需150帝国马克。更复杂的是凶手行为的不可预测性。虽然他有明确的作案手法，但他的犯罪方式或地点并不总是相同。
Sometimes he struck in the expansive allotment gardens on the Yes Barn or along the surrounding streets. Sometimes he interacted with or taunted his victims. Other times he struck without any word or warning. Although the Yes Barn murderer had only committed a few sexual assaults, police believed all his crimes were sexually motivated. Whether or not he raped or molested his victims depended if he thought he could get away with it in time without getting caught.
有时他在Yes Barn广阔的配给花园里作案，有时则在周围的街道上。有时他会与受害者互动或嘲弄她们。其他时候，他则在没有任何言语或警告的情况下发动袭击。尽管Yes Barn杀手只犯下了几起性侵犯案件，但警方认为他所有的罪行都是出于性动机。他是否强奸或猥亵受害者，取决于他是否认为自己能及时脱身而不被抓住。
Time was of the essence. With the attacks occurring more frequently, it signified that the thrill was wearing off quicker for the Yes Barn murderer. He would likely continue to strike more often to satisfy his desire. Eda Schmidt, not her real name, was dressed in her nicest clothes when she boarded the Yes Barn alone and entered an area known as the second class compartment. It was the same section where women had previously been attacked and thrown from the moving train. The compartment was empty when Eda took her seat, but her peaceful journey was soon interrupted
时间至关重要。随着袭击频率的增加，这意味着Yes Barn杀手对刺激的耐受度正在迅速降低。他很可能会更频繁地作案以满足自己的欲望。埃达·施密特（化名）穿着她最好的衣服，独自登上Yes Barn，进入了被称为二等车厢的区域。这正是之前有女性遭到袭击并被从行驶中的火车上扔下的车厢。当埃达坐下时，车厢里空无一人，但她平静的旅程很快被
by a lone male passenger. Slowly he approached Eda. Although she couldn't see his face due to the poor lighting, she could tell that he was wearing a buttonless black jacket and a hat that together looked like some kind of uniform. Suddenly, the man stopped in his tracks. He could tell that Eda didn't appear afraid. Instead, her posture suggested she was on heightened alert as though prepared to defend
一名男性乘客打断了。他慢慢地走向埃达。虽然由于光线昏暗，她看不清他的脸，但她能看出他穿着一件无扣的黑色夹克，戴着一顶帽子，看起来像某种制服。突然，那人停下了脚步。他看得出埃达似乎并不害怕。相反，她的姿势表明她处于高度戒备状态，仿佛准备好保护
herself. Eda thought the man looked confused as to what to do next. Suddenly, he rushed to the side door. Before Eda could react, he yanked it open and launched himself out of the moving train into the darkness. He landed without causing significant injury. Eda watched as he ran towards the nearby Ruhmersburg train station before losing sight of him completely. Once the train came to a stop, Eda's compartment was swarmed by police.
自己。埃达觉得那个人看起来对下一步该做什么感到困惑。突然，他冲向侧门。在埃达反应过来之前，他猛地拉开门，从行驶的火车上跳进了黑暗中。他落地时没有造成严重伤害。埃达看着他跑向附近的鲁默斯堡火车站，随后彻底失去了他的踪影。火车停下后，埃达的车厢被警察包围了。
She was an undercover officer posing as a civilian, hoping to lure out the Yes Barn murderer. Although it couldn't be confirmed with absolute certainty that the man who approached Eda was the killer, his behavior was suspicious enough for police to strongly believe it was. Additionally, while the garden attacker dressed in casual clothing, survivors of the Yes Barn attacks reported that the perpetrator wore some kind of uniform. Police scoured the tracks and nearby stations but found no sign of the man. No one who had crossed paths with the Yes Barn murderer was able to accurately identify
她是一名伪装成平民的卧底警察，希望能引诱出Yes Barn杀手。虽然无法绝对确定接近埃达的那个人就是凶手，但他的行为足够可疑，足以让警方强烈认为他就是凶手。此外，虽然花园袭击者穿着便装，但Yes Barn袭击案的幸存者报告称，罪犯穿着某种制服。警方搜查了铁轨和附近的车站，但没有发现该男子的踪迹。所有与Yes Barn杀手有过交集的人都无法准确辨认
what kind of uniform it was. Their accounts differed, with some describing it as blue while others said black. Some said he wore a hat with an emblem on the front. Many civilian and military uniformed organizations existed within the Nazi regime, and some of their uniforms were very similar, making it difficult for police to narrow the suspect down to any particular group. They considered whether he could be wearing the uniform of the elite German paramilitary organization the Schutzstaffel, widely known as the SS.
那是什么样的制服。他们的描述各不相同，有人说是蓝色的，有人说是黑色的。有人说他戴着一顶前面有徽章的帽子。纳粹政权内存在许多平民和军事制服组织，其中一些制服非常相似，这使得警方很难将嫌疑人锁定在任何特定群体上。他们考虑过他是否可能穿着纳粹精英准军事组织——党卫军（SS）的制服。
While the latest iteration of their uniform was gray, there had been a black version at one stage. Members also wore a distinct peaked cap with an eagle and skull and crossbones insignia on it. The possibility that the Yes Barn murderer could be part of the SS had major implications. Police handled this theory discreetly while continuing with their efforts to catch the killer. More decoys rode on the Yes Barn, including male police officers dressed in feminine clothing.
虽然他们制服的最新版本是灰色的，但曾有一个阶段存在黑色版本。成员们还戴着一顶独特的尖顶帽，上面有鹰和骷髅交叉骨的徽章。Yes Barn杀手可能是党卫军成员的可能性具有重大影响。警方谨慎地处理了这一理论，同时继续努力抓捕凶手。更多的诱饵乘坐Yes Barn，包括穿着女性服装的男警察。
It was hoped the killer wouldn't notice the ruse in the darkened conditions. They lingered on the trains at night, waiting for the killer to strike. The winter sun was yet to rise on the morning of Sunday December 22, 1940, when 30-year-old Elizabeth Bungenair boarded the second-class compartment of the Yes Barn at 6am. She was alone but excited. She was headed to see her military husband who was currently stationed outside of Berlin. But the two would never be reunited. Six hours later, Elizabeth's body was found lying on the railway tracks between Friedrichshaagen
他们希望凶手在黑暗的环境中不会注意到这个诡计。他们晚上在火车上徘徊，等待凶手出击。1940年12月22日星期日清晨，冬日的太阳尚未升起，30岁的伊丽莎白·邦根艾尔在早上6点登上了Yes Barn的二等车厢。她独自一人，但很兴奋。她正要去见她目前驻扎在柏林郊外的军人丈夫。但两人永远无法团聚了。六小时后，伊丽莎白的尸体被发现躺在弗里德里希哈根
and Randsdorf stations. She had been repeatedly struck in the head with a blunt instrument, likely an iron rod or lead pipe. Elizabeth survived the savage beating, but was killed when her body was pushed from the moving train. Elizabeth Bungenair was the fourth killing carried out by the Yes Barn murderer and the first to have been targeted in the morning. It was clear to police that whoever was responsible was changing tactics, as if they knew about
和兰斯多夫车站之间的铁轨上。她的头部被钝器多次击中，很可能是铁棒或铅管。伊丽莎白在残酷的殴打中幸存下来，但当她的身体被从行驶的火车上推下时死亡。伊丽莎白·邦根艾尔是Yes Barn杀手实施的第四起谋杀案，也是第一个在早晨成为目标的受害者。警方很清楚，无论谁是幕后黑手，都在改变策略，就好像他们知道
the decoys monitoring the Yes Barn at night. Police resources were far too stretched to have undercover officers manning the train round the clock. Late on the morning of Sunday December 29, just one week after the murder of Elizabeth Bungenair, another body was discovered on the side of the railroad tracks. 46-year-old Gertrude Zevaert had been travelling alone in the second-class compartment of the Yes Barn hours earlier, when she was struck to the head and thrown from the moving train between the Karlshorst and Rumersborg stations.
晚上有诱饵在监控Yes Barn一样。警方的资源太紧张，无法让卧底警察全天候看守火车。1940年12月29日星期日深夜，就在伊丽莎白·邦根艾尔遇害仅一周后，铁轨旁又发现了一具尸体。46岁的格特鲁德·泽瓦特几小时前独自乘坐Yes Barn的二等车厢，当时她头部遭到重击，并被从卡尔斯霍斯特和鲁默斯堡车站之间行驶的火车上扔下。
By the time she was found, Gertrude was barely clinging to life. She was rushed to hospital, but died later that day. 27-year-old Hedvig E-Bauer was targeted the following Sunday. This time, the Yes Barn murderer used an old tactic. He choked Hedvig until she fell unconscious, then threw her body from the train. Hedvig, who was three months pregnant, was found alive by the railroad tracks near Vulhider station, but later died from the injuries she sustained upon impact. Seven women had now been attacked on the train, five of whom were killed.
当她被发现时，格特鲁德已奄奄一息。她被紧急送往医院，但当天晚些时候死亡。27岁的海德薇格·E-鲍尔在接下来的星期日成为目标。这一次，Yes Barn杀手使用了旧战术。他掐住海德薇格直到她失去知觉，然后将她的尸体从火车上扔下。怀孕三个月的海德薇格在沃尔希德车站附近的铁轨旁被发现时还活着，但后来因撞击造成的伤害而死亡。现在已有七名女性在火车上遭到袭击，其中五人死亡。
Despite the government's best efforts to keep news of the serial killer under wraps, rumours of his actions were spreading across Berlin. The police requested permission from Josef Goebbels to print an article in a city-wide newspaper to officially address the crimes and warn commuters. Goebbels reluctantly agreed, but on the condition that all it said was that a person was, quote, making trouble on the Yes Barn. The article did divulge that women had been thrown from the vehicle, but it didn't mention how many, or that they'd died as a result.
尽管政府尽了最大努力封锁连环杀手的消息，但关于他行为的传言还是在柏林传开了。警方请求约瑟夫·戈培尔批准在全市范围的报纸上刊登一篇文章，正式处理这些罪行并警告通勤者。戈培尔勉强同意了，但条件是文章只能说有人在Yes Barn上“制造麻烦”。文章确实透露了有女性被从车上扔下，但没有提到具体人数，也没有提到她们因此死亡。
Goebbels also permitted matching flyers to be distributed to the public, but capped the amount at 2,000. He forbade an announcement from being broadcast on the radio, as he didn't want word to spread outside of Berlin. Goebbels had his own idea about how to ensure the safety of the city's female passengers. He requested that men volunteer to chaperone lone women travelling on the Yes Barn at night. The only men who could apply for this role were members of a paramilitary wing of the Nazi party, who enforced the regime through physical violence.
戈培尔还允许向公众分发配套的传单，但将数量限制在2000份。他禁止在广播中发布公告，因为他不希望消息传出柏林。戈培尔有自己的想法来确保城市女性乘客的安全。他要求男性志愿者在晚上护送独自乘坐Yes Barn的女性。唯一可以申请此角色的男性是纳粹党准军事派系的成员，他们通过暴力手段强制执行政权。
These men were referred to as brown shirts, named after the colour of their uniform. To be given the role of a brown shirt was considered an honour reserved for trustworthy men with no criminal record. The Minister of Propaganda's strategy appeared successful. As lone female passengers were escorted on the Yes Barn by brown shirts, the remainder of January passed with no further incidents. Mother of three, 39-year-old Johanna Voight stood alone at the Rumorsborg train station. It was 10pm on Tuesday, February 11, and Johanna was nervous.
这些人被称为“褐衫军”，以他们制服的颜色命名。被授予褐衫军的角色被认为是一种荣誉，仅限于没有犯罪记录的可靠男性。宣传部长的策略似乎奏效了。随着独自乘坐Yes Barn的女性乘客由褐衫军护送，一月的剩余时间里没有再发生任何事件。三个孩子的母亲，39岁的约翰娜·沃伊特独自站在鲁默斯堡火车站。那是2月11日星期二晚上10点，约翰娜很紧张。
She knew about the Yes Barn murderer, and given she was pregnant, Johanna feared for the safety of her unborn baby. Her worry must have been palpable, because an experienced brown shirt approached having spent the day assisting women on their travels. Typically, women had to check in as part of the programme, and a brown shirt would then be authorised by Joseph Goebbels himself to personally escort her. Johanna hadn't made any such arrangements, but she asked the brown shirt if he would be willing to accompany her to Karlshorst station.
她知道Yes Barn杀手的事，而且考虑到她怀孕了，约翰娜为未出生婴儿的安全感到担忧。她的担忧一定是显而易见的，因为一名经验丰富的褐衫军走过来，他那天一直在协助女性出行。通常，女性必须作为计划的一部分进行登记，然后褐衫军会得到约瑟夫·戈培尔本人的授权来亲自护送她。约翰娜没有做任何此类安排，但她询问那名褐衫军是否愿意陪她去卡尔斯霍斯特车站。
Although he'd already clocked off, Karlshorst was only one station away, so the man agreed. The pair entered the empty second-class compartment and took a seat. As the train took off and gained momentum, the brown shirt suddenly pulled an iron rod out from his jacket sleeve and immediately struck Johanna in the head with it. He then dragged her unconscious body to the door of the train and pushed her out. Johanna survived the initial attack, but by the time she was found, she'd succumbed to her injuries. There was nothing amongst Johanna's belongings that hinted towards her killer's identity.
虽然他已经下班了，但卡尔斯霍斯特只有一个站的距离，所以那个人同意了。两人进入空荡荡的二等车厢并坐下。当火车启动并加速时，褐衫军突然从夹克袖子里掏出一根铁棒，立即击中了约翰娜的头部。然后他把她失去知觉的身体拖到火车门口并把她推了下去。约翰娜在最初的袭击中幸存下来，但当她被发现时，她已经因伤势过重而死亡。约翰娜的随身物品中没有任何暗示凶手身份的线索。
Rather, it was the absence of a certain item that gave investigators pause. Like several of the other victims, Johanna Voigt had been travelling on the S-Bahn without a ticket, an offence punishable by fine. While measures were in place to prevent people from riding the S-Bahn without a valid ticket, it was to be expected that the odd passenger would slip through without pain. However, it struck investigators as odd that so many of the murder victims were riding freely. Given it was highly unlikely that all of them had managed to avoid crossing paths with a
相反，正是某件物品的缺失让调查人员停了下来。像其他几名受害者一样，约翰娜·沃伊特在没有票的情况下乘坐S-Bahn，这是一种可处以罚款的违法行为。虽然已经采取了措施防止人们在没有有效车票的情况下乘坐S-Bahn，但偶尔有乘客溜过去也是意料之中的。然而，让调查人员感到奇怪的是，这么多谋杀受害者都是免费乘车的。鉴于她们所有人都不太可能成功避开
ticket inspector, investigators developed a theory. If the killer was a current or former S-Bahn employee or posing as one, he could approach his victims without causing alarm. Some of the victims could have been lured onto the train with the promise of a free and safe journey. Alternatively, the killer could have confronted the women under the guise of checking their tickets before launching an attack. Curiously, Geda Kagoe recalled that her attacker had approached her shortly before she boarded
检票员，调查人员提出了一个理论。如果凶手是现任或前任S-Bahn员工，或者冒充员工，他就可以在不引起警觉的情况下接近受害者。一些受害者可能被承诺免费且安全的旅程而诱骗上车。或者，凶手可能在发动袭击前以查票为幌子与这些女性对质。奇怪的是，格达·卡戈回忆说，她的袭击者在登上S-Bahn前不久接近了她，并指引她去二等车厢。
the S-Bahn and directed her to the second-class compartment. Considering he was dressed in uniform, she assumed he was a railroad employee and obeyed his command without question. Elizabeth Bendoff had also been told to board the second-class compartment by a uniformed man shortly before her attack. Yet, both women clarified that he wasn't impersonating a ticket inspector. The S-Bahn was staffed by employees of the National Railroad, whose uniforms included a hat adorned with an eagle clutching a swastika.
考虑到他穿着制服，她以为他是铁路员工，便毫无疑问地服从了他的命令。伊丽莎白·本多夫在袭击前不久也被一名穿制服的男子告知要登上二等车厢。然而，两位女性都澄清说，他并没有冒充检票员。S-Bahn由国家铁路的员工配备，他们的制服包括一顶装饰着鹰抓万字徽章的帽子。
Given that this matched witness descriptions of the killer, police had initially considered whether the offender could be a railroad worker. The problem was that there were over 5,000 uniformed employees of the National Railroad spread across 28 departments, so narrowing down the suspect list would be no easy feat. Roughly a quarter were eliminated immediately based on survivors' descriptions. The rest had to be questioned in addition to having their work schedules collated, checked and verified. Geda Kagoe and Elizabeth Bendoff were shown thousands of photos of men who worked for
鉴于这与目击者对凶手的描述相符，警方最初考虑该罪犯是否可能是铁路工人。问题在于，国家铁路有超过5000名穿制服的员工分布在28个部门，因此缩小嫌疑人名单绝非易事。大约四分之一的人根据幸存者的描述被立即排除。其余的人除了需要接受询问外，他们的工作时间表还必须进行整理、核对和验证。格达·卡戈和伊丽莎白·本多夫被展示了数千张为
the S-Bahn, but neither woman recognized their attacker. 8,000 people who lived around the Friedrichsfelder Gardens were also looked into. Under pressure from Josef Goebbels to solve the case, hundreds more undercover and uniformed police officers were tasked with riding the S-Bahn and manning the key train stations along the way. With no distinguishing features to be on the lookout for, they questioned every man they came across. Every train platform and compartment was diligently searched for any evidence of the killer's
S-Bahn工作的男性的照片，但两人都没有认出她们的袭击者。居住在弗里德里希斯费尔德花园周围的8000人也受到了调查。在约瑟夫·戈培尔要求破案的压力下，数百名卧底和穿制服的警察被派往乘坐S-Bahn并驻守沿途的关键火车站。由于没有明显的特征可寻，他们询问了遇到的每一个男人。每一个火车站台和车厢都被勤奋地搜查，寻找任何凶手存在的证据，
presence, which sometimes required entire sections of the train line to be shut down. Police were finally able to publish a more detailed newspaper article about the case, this time revealing that multiple women had been killed. They further increased the reward on offer to 13,000 Reichsmarks for information pertaining to Johanna Voigt's murder or any of the previous attacks, while warning women against riding in the second class compartment. The article also detailed the possibility that the offender was wearing a national railway uniform or something similar.
这有时需要关闭整段铁路线。警方终于能够发表一篇关于此案的更详细的报纸文章，这次透露有多名女性被杀。他们进一步将悬赏金额提高到13000帝国马克，以征集有关约翰娜·沃伊特谋杀案或之前任何袭击的线索，同时警告女性不要乘坐二等车厢。文章还详细说明了罪犯可能穿着国家铁路制服或类似服装的可能性。
Police were inundated with roughly 1,500 tips from the public. While none of the tip-offs led to the identification of the perpetrator, the heavy-handed investigation had seemingly brought an end to his killing spree. By Thursday, July 3, 1941, five months had passed since the S-Bahn murderer had a last strike. With the increased police presence and the public now on high alert, commuters were safer than ever before. In the early morning hours, 35-year-old Frieda Kotsio wrote the S-Bahn without incident.
警方收到了大约1500条来自公众的线索。虽然没有任何线索能锁定罪犯，但高压调查似乎结束了他的杀戮狂潮。到1941年7月3日星期四，距离S-Bahn杀手最后一次作案已经过去了五个月。随着警察力量的增加和公众的高度警惕，通勤者比以往任何时候都更安全。在清晨，35岁的弗里达·科齐奥乘坐S-Bahn时没有发生任何意外。
She disembarked at Ruhmersburg station along with nine other women and one man. As they left the platform, the group scattered to take their different routes home. Frieda headed alone down a path towards the nearby allotment gardens. Once she reached the quiet and darkened grounds, she was struck in the back of the head with an iron bar. The beating continued once she was on the ground, resulting in Frieda's skull caving in. Her attacker then tore off her clothing below the waist and proceeded to rape her before
她在鲁默斯堡车站与另外九名女性和一名男性一起下车。当他们离开站台时，这群人分散开来，各自走回家的路。弗里达独自沿着一条小路走向附近的配给花园。当她到达安静而黑暗的场地时，后脑勺被铁棒击中。当她倒在地上时，殴打仍在继续，导致弗里达的头骨塌陷。她的袭击者随后撕掉了她腰部以下的衣服，并在逃离现场前强奸了她。
fleeing the scene. Frieda's bloodied and partially naked body was found shortly after, making her the eighth fatality at the hands of the S-Bahn murderer. Frieda's death was a blow to investigators. Having narrowed in on the S-Bahn, they'd overlooked the perpetrator's previous hunting grounds and hadn't thought to put safety measures in place in the allotment gardens. The police felt partially responsible for Frieda Kotsio's murder, as it was clear that the killer knew the police had taken over the train system.
弗里达血迹斑斑且半裸的尸体不久后被发现，使她成为S-Bahn杀手手中的第八名受害者。弗里达的死对调查人员是一个打击。在将重点缩小到S-Bahn后，他们忽视了罪犯之前的狩猎场，也没有想到在配给花园采取安全措施。警方对弗里达·科齐奥的谋杀案负有部分责任，因为很明显，凶手知道警方已经接管了火车系统。
Instead of changing tactics to flush him out, their defiant actions had forced the killer away from the very spot they might have otherwise caught him. Still, the gardens provided evidence that the S-Bahn did not. A set of fresh shoe prints were pressed in the dirt surrounding Frieda's body and led 50 meters beyond, indicating that someone had knelt down next to her body and inspected it before running from the scene. Plaster molds of the prints revealed the shoeing question was a size 39.5 with an extra thick rubber sole and distinctive tread pattern.
他们强硬的行动并没有改变策略来引诱他出来，反而迫使凶手离开了他们本可以抓住他的地方。尽管如此，花园确实提供了S-Bahn没有的证据。弗里达尸体周围的泥土中印着一串新鲜的鞋印，并延伸到50米外，表明有人在逃离现场前曾跪在她的尸体旁检查过。鞋印的石膏模型显示，该鞋的尺码为39.5码，带有超厚橡胶底和独特的胎面花纹。
They matched shoes manufactured by a specialist podiatry company. As luck would have it, the company kept well-documented records of all their customers, including those who had purchased the size 39.5 shoe. Armed with this list, investigators began tracking down and interviewing each of the customers. Investors were fighting in the war or lived too far away and were promptly ruled out. But there was one man that caught investigators' interest. He lived near the Rumorspaw train station, right by the allotment gardens where dozens
它们与一家专业足病公司制造的鞋子相匹配。幸运的是，该公司保存了所有客户的详细记录，包括那些购买了39.5码鞋子的客户。拿着这份名单，调查人员开始追踪并采访每一位客户。调查人员有的在战争中服役，有的住得太远，很快被排除。但有一个人引起了调查人员的兴趣。他住在鲁默斯堡火车站附近，就在几十名
of women had been attacked. He was a carpenter named V. Hyman. A check of his police records revealed that Hyman had a criminal conviction for voyeurism, having previously been caught spying on a couple having sex. It was the only blemish on an otherwise clean record. Hyman was taken in for questioning, during which he denied involvement in any of the Esban murderers' crimes. In the meantime, his home was searched for any evidence that could link him to the case.
女性遭到袭击的配给花园旁边。他是一名名叫V·海曼的木匠。对他警察记录的检查显示，海曼曾因偷窥罪被定罪，此前曾被抓到偷窥一对夫妇发生性关系。这是他原本清白的记录中唯一的污点。海曼被带去审讯，期间他否认参与了任何S-Bahn杀手的罪行。与此同时，他的家被搜查，寻找任何可能将他与此案联系起来的证据。
Investigators found a pair of custom podiatry shoes, and compared them to the molds taken alongside Frida Kotziol's body. They were a match. When Hyman was informed of this discovery, he admitted that he'd stumbled across Frida's body and had knelt down to inspect it. Once he realized she was dead, he fled the scene. Hyman didn't admit to this earlier because he was scared of being used as a scapegoat. He was also mindful that the penalty for sex-based crimes were severely amplified during the
调查人员发现了一双定制的足病鞋，并将它们与在弗里达·科齐奥尸体旁采集的模型进行了比较。它们是匹配的。当海曼被告知这一发现时，他承认他偶然发现了弗里达的尸体，并跪下来检查。一旦意识到她已经死了，他就逃离了现场。海曼没有早点承认这一点，因为他害怕被当作替罪羊。他还意识到，在灯火管制期间，性犯罪的惩罚被严重加重了。
blackout. Given his history as a convicted sex offender, he feared that he'd be handed a death sentence despite his innocence, just so authorities could close the case. Police were forced to drop the Hyman lead when they discovered that he had solid alibis for a large percentage of the Esban murderers' attacks, thus ruling him out as the perpetrator. Whether he'd face any repercussions for failing to report Frida Kotziol's murder remained to be seen. Whatever the case, police were back to square one.
鉴于他作为性犯罪者的前科，他担心即使自己是无辜的，也会被判处死刑，只是为了让当局结案。当警方发现海曼在S-Bahn杀手的大部分袭击中都有可靠的不在场证明时，他们被迫放弃了海曼这条线索，从而排除了他是罪犯的可能性。他是否会因未报告弗里达·科齐奥的谋杀案而面临任何后果还有待观察。无论如何，警方又回到了原点。
Following the murder of Frida Kotziol, police extended their covert surveillance to the Friedrichsfelder allotment gardens, while also observing the Esban more discreetly. Although these preventative measures had previously deterred the perpetrator temporarily, the police knew they were unsustainable in the long term. Once officers were forced to return to other duties, the Esban murderer would no doubt resume his spree. Meanwhile, investigators were still making their way through the long list of employees from the National Railroad, questioning everyone about the murders.
在弗里达·科齐奥被谋杀后，警方将秘密监视范围扩大到了弗里德里希斯费尔德配给花园，同时也更谨慎地观察S-Bahn。虽然这些预防措施此前曾暂时阻止了罪犯，但警方知道从长远来看它们是不可持续的。一旦警察被迫返回其他职责，S-Bahn杀手无疑会恢复他的狂潮。与此同时，调查人员仍在处理国家铁路员工的长名单，询问每个人关于谋杀案的情况。
One so far had raised their suspicions and the ticket inspector lead was a dead end. Police considered the possibility that the killer wasn't a railroad employee at all, but had been wearing a fake or stolen uniform. Then, a week after the murder of Frida Kotziol, as they were wrapping up close to six months' worth of railroad employee interviews, there seemed to be a much needed breakthrough. Police concluded the interviews with a standard question. Have you noticed anything suspicious about any of your co-workers? One man had.
到目前为止，有一个人引起了他们的怀疑，而检票员的线索是一条死胡同。警方考虑了凶手根本不是铁路员工，而是穿着假制服或偷来的制服的可能性。然后，在弗里达·科齐奥被谋杀一周后，当他们结束了近六个月的铁路员工采访时，似乎出现了一个急需的突破。警方以一个标准问题结束了采访：你有没有注意到你的同事有什么可疑之处？有一个人注意到了。
He'd spotted a colleague, 28-year-old Paul Ugozov, leaving work in the middle of his shift by jumping over a fence. When confronted, Ugozov said he was off to see a woman. He returned some time later without any of his superiors noticing his absence. Ugozov had worked for the railroad for six years, having worked his way up from a temporary role as a manual laborer to a permanent position as an auxiliary signalman. He was stationed in a tower near the Rumsburg station, where he worked mostly alone, monitoring signalling that ensured the trains ran efficiently and safely.
他发现一名同事，28岁的保罗·乌戈佐夫，在轮班中途跳过栅栏离开工作岗位。当被质问时，乌戈佐夫说他要去见一个女人。他在一段时间后回来，没有任何上级注意到他的缺席。乌戈佐夫在铁路工作了六年，从体力劳动的临时工一路晋升为辅助信号员的固定职位。他驻扎在鲁默斯堡车站附近的一座塔楼里，大部分时间独自工作，监控确保火车高效安全运行的信号。
Despite having worked at the company for a long time, Ugozov wasn't close to his colleagues. Many didn't even know his name. Paul Ugozov had already been questioned in relation to the S-Bahn murders. Records showed he had been working at the time of the attacks, and his role had him positioned in a signal tower, a building along the railroad that was independent of the stations. He was not required to ride the S-Bahn as part of his duties or interact with passengers. Officers had found Ugozov assiduous and industrious, and he was praised by his superiors for his unblemished work history.
尽管在公司工作了很长时间，但乌戈佐夫与同事并不亲近。许多人甚至不知道他的名字。保罗·乌戈佐夫此前曾因S-Bahn谋杀案受到询问。记录显示他在袭击发生时正在工作，他的角色使他驻扎在信号塔里，这是一座独立于车站的铁路沿线建筑。他不需要作为职责的一部分乘坐S-Bahn或与乘客互动。警官们发现乌戈佐夫勤奋刻苦，并因其无瑕的工作记录受到上级的称赞。
He was ultimately ruled out of the investigation. However, when his colleague reported Ugozov's history of disappearing mid-shift, his roster no longer provided him with an alibi. While Ugozov didn't have a violent criminal record or history of sexual deviancy, he had been arrested for burglary some years prior. Even with this conviction, there was nothing in Ugozov's background to suggest he was capable of the S-Bahn murderers' crimes. He was a hard-working German national and married father of two.
他最终被排除在调查之外。然而，当他的同事报告乌戈佐夫轮班中途消失的历史时，他的排班表不再为他提供不在场证明。虽然乌戈佐夫没有暴力犯罪记录或性变态史，但他几年前曾因入室盗窃被捕。即使有这个定罪，乌戈佐夫的背景中也没有任何迹象表明他有能力犯下S-Bahn杀手的罪行。他是一名勤奋的德国公民，也是两个孩子的已婚父亲。
Most importantly, he was a long time and upstanding member of the Nazi Party. Ugozov relished being a Nazi Party member, and his loyalty was rewarded with the highly regarded position of Sergeant in one of the group's paramilitary offshoots, colloquially known as the Brownshirts. This role saw him tasked with safely escorting women to and from the S-Bahn during the height of the killings. Ugozov dismissed the allegations that he'd previously left his work post, saying whoever accused him of that was either lying or mistaken.
最重要的是，他是一名长期且正直的纳粹党成员。乌戈佐夫很享受作为纳粹党成员的身份，他的忠诚得到了回报，担任了该组织准军事分支之一的军士长，俗称“褐衫军”。这个角色使他负责在杀戮高峰期安全护送女性往返于S-Bahn。乌戈佐夫驳斥了关于他之前离开工作岗位的指控，称任何指责他的人要么是在撒谎，要么是弄错了。
It took some time before he finally confessed that it was true. He explained that he was having an affair with a married woman who lived nearby. He'd initially lied to avoid getting into trouble with his wife or employers. The woman confirmed she and Ugozov were having an affair, and while this supported Ugozov's claims, it didn't clear him as a suspect. All it did was prove he had a habit of abandoning his work post on the sly. Upon re-examining Ugozov's work schedule for the nights of the murders, investigators discovered that the killings had occurred at times when no trains had been passing through.
过了好一会儿，他才终于承认这是真的。他解释说，他与附近的一名已婚妇女有染。他最初撒谎是为了避免惹上妻子或雇主的麻烦。那个女人证实她和乌戈佐夫有染，虽然这支持了乌戈佐夫的说法，但这并没有洗清他的嫌疑。这只能证明他有偷偷离开工作岗位的习惯。在重新检查谋杀案发生当晚乌戈佐夫的工作时间表时，调查人员发现杀戮发生时没有火车经过。
As Ugozov worked alone, this meant he could have left his signal tower without anyone noticing his absence or lack of input. A search of Ugozov's home near the Friedrichsfelder Gardens uncovered several uniforms and matching caps, including those he wore while on the job. At first glance, the clothing appeared clean, but a microscopic examination of the fabric revealed blood stains, including a large amount around the crotch area of his pants. Ugozov claimed the blood had come from his wife, who had been sick three days earlier. She corroborated this story.
由于乌戈佐夫独自工作，这意味着他可以在没有人注意到他缺席或缺乏投入的情况下离开信号塔。对乌戈佐夫在弗里德里希斯费尔德花园附近的家进行的搜查发现了多套制服和配套的帽子，包括他在工作时穿的那些。乍一看，衣服看起来很干净，但对织物的显微镜检查显示有血迹，包括裤子裆部周围有大量血迹。乌戈佐夫声称血迹来自他三天前生病的妻子。她证实了这个故事。
Ugozov added that he'd also recently cut his finger and had wiped the blood on his pants. Testing confirmed the blood was indeed human, but there wasn't enough to establish what type it was, and as DNA testing didn't exist at the time, nothing else could be ascertained. Blood stains were also found on Ugozov's work jacket. Forensics concluded that this blood spatter was consistent with a violent attack. Inside Ugozov's home, investigators also found a sports shirt, dark pants and a blue visor cap, similar to the outfit worn by the flashlight-wielding menace in the Friedrichsfelder Gardens.
乌戈佐夫补充说，他最近也割伤了手指，并把血擦在了裤子上。测试证实血迹确实是人类的，但没有足够的量来确定是什么类型的，而且由于当时不存在DNA测试，无法确定其他任何事情。在乌戈佐夫的工作夹克上也发现了血迹。法医得出结论，这些血迹与暴力袭击相符。在乌戈佐夫家中，调查人员还发现了一件运动衫、深色裤子和一顶蓝色遮阳帽，类似于弗里德里希斯费尔德花园中那个挥舞手电筒的威胁者所穿的服装。
It was an area Ugozov was familiar with as he had to pass through the gardens on his way home from work. Due to his shift work, this often took place late at night, and sometimes Ugozov was on his bike. Ugozov denied doing anything wrong, but after intense questioning, he eventually relented. He admitted to being the bike-riding flashlight-wielding man who had harassed women the year prior, but maintained the worst offense he'd committed was once grabbing a woman. Ugozov was taken to the Friedrichsfelder Gardens to pinpoint exactly where he had carried out
这是一个乌戈佐夫熟悉的地方，因为他下班回家的路上必须经过花园。由于他的轮班工作，这通常发生在深夜，有时乌戈佐夫骑着自行车。乌戈佐夫否认做了任何错事，但在激烈的审讯后，他最终让步了。他承认自己就是那个骑自行车、挥舞手电筒、在前一年骚扰女性的男人，但坚称他犯下的最严重的罪行只是曾经抓住过一个女人。乌戈佐夫被带到弗里德里希斯费尔德花园，以准确指出他在哪里实施了
the minor offenses he had confessed to. It soon became clear that Ugozov had committed far more than he was willing to admit to. After the next three hours he struggled to keep track of where everything had taken place. At one stage he pointed out a railway underpass as the location where he'd scared a woman by shining his flashlight at her. This was actually the place where a felony assault had reportedly taken place. Ugozov pointed out two more spots that he claimed were the setting of minor altercations, and in fact, they were the sites of two attempted murders.
他所承认的轻微罪行。很快就很清楚，乌戈佐夫犯下的罪行远比他愿意承认的多。在接下来的三个小时里，他很难记住所有事情发生的地方。有一次，他指着一个铁路地下通道，说那是他通过用手电筒照向一个女人来吓唬她的地方。这实际上是据报道发生重罪袭击的地方。乌戈佐夫指出了另外两个他声称是轻微冲突发生地的地方，事实上，它们是两起谋杀未遂案的现场。
Out of all the survivors, only Gertrude Nisfant was able to positively identify Paul Ugozov as her attacker after seeing him in police custody. He'd confronted her on her parent's doorstep, and the pair had a brief interaction before he had attacked. Once the garden tour was over, Ugozov asked to speak with the officer in charge of the Serious Crimes Unit, Commissioner Wilhelm Lutka. Investigators suspected this was a tactic, and Ugozov was perhaps going to use his standing in the Nazi party to influence a senior member of police.
在所有幸存者中，只有格特鲁德·尼斯凡特在警察拘留期间看到保罗·乌戈佐夫后，能够肯定地认出他是袭击者。他在她父母的家门口与她对质，两人在袭击前进行了简短的互动。花园之旅结束后，乌戈佐夫要求与重案组负责人、威廉·卢特卡专员交谈。调查人员怀疑这是一种策略，乌戈佐夫可能打算利用他在纳粹党的地位来影响高级警官。
His request was granted, but when Ugozov was led into the interrogation room, he was confronted with five skulls belonging to the Esban murderers' victims. They were placed on the center of a table with a light shining directly on them, their hollow eyes aimed in Ugozov's direction. Ugozov looked at Commissioner Lutka and immediately remarked, You gotta help me. He began to insist that he was a loyal member of the Nazi party, and went on to describe the violent acts he had committed against the Jewish people in the hopes that would
他的请求得到了批准，但当乌戈佐夫被带进审讯室时，他面对的是属于S-Bahn杀手受害者的五个头骨。它们被放在桌子中央，一盏灯直接照在它们身上，它们空洞的眼睛对准了乌戈佐夫的方向。乌戈佐夫看着卢特卡专员，立即说道：“你得帮我。”他开始坚持说自己是纳粹党的忠实成员，并继续描述他对犹太人犯下的暴力行为，希望这能
endear him to Lutka. Commissioner Lutka had endured the highs and lows of the Esban murderer investigation, and wanted the case solved more than anyone. He would later remark, Rarely has the work of the Berlin criminal police, particularly homicide, been of such strong public interest. Lutka knew the longer citizens lived in fear of the threat, the more they would question the abilities of those tasked with protecting them. Pretending to be sympathetic, Commissioner Lutka told Paul Ugozov that if he wanted help,
博得卢特卡的欢心。卢特卡专员忍受了S-Bahn杀手调查的起起落落，比任何人都更想破案。他后来评论道：“柏林刑事警察，特别是凶杀案的工作，很少引起如此强烈的公众兴趣。”卢特卡知道，公民在恐惧中生活的时间越长，他们就越会质疑那些负责保护他们的人的能力。卢特卡专员假装同情，告诉保罗·乌戈佐夫，如果他想得到帮助，
he would need to tell the police exactly what he'd done. Ugozov's next move was unexpected. He admitted to committing the murders, but described them incorrectly, saying he had stabbed the women to death. He was trying to muddy the waters, so it would be difficult to convict him. Commissioner Lutka pressed Ugozov to reveal the truth by methodically going over all the evidence, including the skulls that were sitting before them. Large holes were clearly visible from where they had each been struck with a heavy blunt
他需要告诉警察他到底做了什么。乌戈佐夫的下一步行动出人意料。他承认犯下了谋杀罪，但描述得不正确，说他是用刀刺死了这些女性。他试图混淆视听，以便很难给他定罪。卢特卡专员通过有条不紊地检查所有证据，包括摆在他们面前的头骨，迫使乌戈佐夫揭露真相。从它们各自被重型钝器击中的地方可以清楚地看到大洞，
object, injuries that couldn't have been inflicted with a knife. At this point, the blood drained from Ugozov's face. He said the injury must have occurred when the victim fell from the train, even though that possibility had already been excluded by forensic experts. Commissioner Lutka asked Ugozov point blank, what did you beat these women to death with? Reaching the end of the line, an ashen and trembling Ugozov replied, with a lead cable. The floodgates had opened, and Paul Ugozov confessed to everything in correct detail. He spoke of the attacks in the garden and how he'd adjusted his tactics with each mistake,
这些伤口是不可能用刀造成的。此时，乌戈佐夫的脸变得苍白。他说伤口一定是在受害者从火车上掉下来时造成的，尽管这种可能性已经被法医专家排除了。卢特卡专员直截了当地问乌戈佐夫：“你用什么把这些女人打死的？”走到尽头的乌戈佐夫脸色苍白，颤抖着回答：“用一根铅缆。”闸门打开了，保罗·乌戈佐夫详细地承认了一切。他谈到了花园里的袭击，以及他是如何随着每一次错误调整战术的，
eventually committing his crimes on the S-Bahn, which he was innately familiar with. He knew the second class compartment had the fewest passengers and was empty more often, making it the ideal spot to strike. He approached alone female passengers while wearing his work or brown shirts uniform, as he knew they would trust his authority. After each murder, he returned home to his family, who were none the wiser. He also revealed that upon pushing one of his victims off the S-Bahn, he had tracked to the site where her body landed.
最终在S-Bahn上犯下了罪行，他对那里非常熟悉。他知道二等车厢乘客最少，而且空置的频率更高，这使它成为袭击的理想地点。他穿着工作服或褐衫军制服接近独自乘坐的女性乘客，因为他知道她们会信任他的权威。每次谋杀后，他都回到家中陪伴家人，他们对此一无所知。他还透露，在将其中一名受害者推下S-Bahn后，他曾追踪到她尸体落下的地点。
He thought it would give him a second rush, but instead he felt sickened upon seeing what he had done. He didn't revisit any of his crime scenes after that. In a written confession, Ugozov provided an insight into how his murderous urge developed, but it was really an attempt to use his political ties to sway public opinion. He wrote, A few years ago I had sex with a stripper and then went to a Jewish doctor. The Jew who knew I was a Nazi Party member has, out of hatred for the Nazis, mistreated
他以为这会给他第二次刺激，但当看到自己的所作所为时，他感到恶心。此后他没有再重访任何犯罪现场。在一份书面供词中，乌戈佐夫提供了关于他的杀人冲动是如何发展的见解，但这实际上是他试图利用政治关系来左右公众舆论的尝试。他写道：“几年前，我和一个脱衣舞娘发生了性关系，然后去看了一个犹太医生。那个知道我是纳粹党成员的犹太人，出于对纳粹的仇恨，虐待了
my gonorrhea, the consequence of which has affected my state of mind. I would like this considered for sentencing purposes. Therefore, I am not responsible for my actions. Also, please bear in mind that I am a Party member. He also tried to pin his behaviour on head injuries he sustained in his youth, though he showed no evidence of brain damage. In fact, in their report, the investigating police described Ugozov as having a, completely cold and calculating nature, without any nerves or inhibitions when it came to satisfying
我的淋病，其后果影响了我的精神状态。我希望在量刑时考虑这一点。因此，我不对我的行为负责。另外，请记住我是一名党员。”他还试图将自己的行为归咎于他在青年时期受到的头部损伤，尽管他没有表现出任何脑损伤的证据。事实上，调查警察在报告中描述乌戈佐夫具有“完全冷酷和计算的本性，在满足他的性冲动时没有任何神经或抑制”。
his sexual urges. The report added that he had, willingly and consciously exploited the blackout, giving him greater opportunity for his attacks, and facilitated his escapes. Paul Ugozov's trial commenced just two weeks after his arrest. Any hope that he standing within the Nazi Party would absolve him of his crimes were short-lived, as he was found guilty for the murder of eight women and the attempted murder of six others. Calling Ugozov a beast in human form, deservedly eliminated from the national community, the
报告补充说，他“自愿且有意识地利用了灯火管制，这为他的袭击提供了更大的机会，并促进了他的逃脱”。保罗·乌戈佐夫的审判在他被捕仅两周后就开始了。他希望他在纳粹党内的地位能免除他的罪行，但这种希望很快就破灭了，因为他被判谋杀八名女性和谋杀未遂六名女性罪名成立。称乌戈佐夫为“人形野兽”，理应从民族共同体中清除，
judge sentenced Ugozov to death. Seemingly accepting that his previous explanations had failed, when Ugozov was asked why he felt compelled to kill women, he finally revealed, because I hate them. There was no death row within the German criminal justice system, a death sentence was to be carried out within hours of being handed down. Paul Ugozov was executed by decapitation the following day. His remains were sent to the Institute of Anatomy and Biology to be used for research
法官判处乌戈佐夫死刑。乌戈佐夫似乎意识到他之前的辩解已经失效，当被问及为何执意杀害女性时，他终于吐露心声：因为我恨她们。德国刑事司法系统中并没有死囚牢房，死刑判决下达后几小时内就会执行。保罗·乌戈佐夫于次日被斩首处决。他的遗体被送往解剖与生物学研究所用于研究。
purposes. A few weeks later, a letter was sent to Ugozov's wife. It was a bill from the prison. Ugozov's execution had caused wear and tear to the guillotine blade, and his wife would have to pay to service it. Two days after Ugozov's execution, Florida's Miami Herald newspaper printed an article that read, Strangely, a Berlin court sentenced a railway worker to death because he killed eight women.
几周后，一封信寄给了乌戈佐夫的妻子。那是监狱寄来的账单。乌戈佐夫的处决导致断头台刀片磨损，他的妻子必须支付维修费用。乌戈佐夫被处决两天后，佛罗里达州的《迈阿密先驱报》刊登了一篇文章，上面写道：奇怪的是，柏林一家法院判处一名铁路工人死刑，因为他杀害了八名女性。
Under the circumstances, it would seem that the man would have been placed in the army, or better yet, in a bomber. Then he could have bombed and killed women during blackouts in England. Instead of being executed, he would have been rewarded with medals, a monument might have been erected to him. It would punish one man because he murdered. It organizes armies and trains them to murder on a wholesale scale. Paul Ugozov is sentenced to death for killing eight women.
在这种情况下，此人似乎本应被编入军队，或者更好的是，成为一名轰炸机飞行员。那样他就可以在英国的灯火管制期间轰炸并杀害女性。他不仅不会被处决，反而会获得勋章，甚至可能为他竖立纪念碑。社会惩罚一个杀人犯，却组织军队并训练他们进行大规模屠杀。保罗·乌戈佐夫因杀害八名女性而被判处死刑。
Adolf Hitler is saluted and cheered because he has killed thousands of men, women and children. Ugozov was sentenced to death for killing eight women. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
阿道夫·希特勒因杀害了成千上万的男人、女人和儿童而受到敬礼和欢呼。乌戈佐夫因杀害八名女性而被判处死刑。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。